a big schedule ahead of us today so
welcome to all elected members in staff
to today's meeting I am going to ask his
worship to open our Hui for us and then
I'll move through the agenda as quickly
as I possibly can for you all and just
to note there is a late I assume that's
been presented by councilor cricket if
you haven't already updated your board
box could you please do so now while his
worship opens our meeting that will give
you a chance to see that new update
that's been put on board box in just a
reminder that today's meeting will be
recorded and the public excluded session
will be removed from the recording and
it will be posted live through what live
isn't now posted afterwards for the
public to get a link so with that in
mind I'll hand it over to his wishes
Amir to open with open our meeting thank
you and it's certainly an amazing time
that we're going through if you're a
history buff it's sort of got an edge of
excitement to it as well as all the
other responsibilities that we have the
I've focused this week on buying local
now a lot of people have had over the
years by New Zealand or by local
campaigns and we've been I've always
been a bit reluctant because if you're
saying buy local it's that's becoming a
bit exclusive and it can lead to
repercussions or so you don't want that
stuff well we don't want you kind of
attitude can screw it up so we've got to
be careful about it but I think it might
work because it's such an unusual
situation than we find ourselves and and
I hope there won't be any repercussions
thank you thank you your worship
appreciate their in look forward to more
buying local I'm sure
we will be true and so I'm just going to
move into apologies I see councillor
Louis has joined us so I'm not sure that
there are any apologies from today
unless someone has one if you just want
to unmute yourself and let us know that
would be great
right so no apologies that interest
register obviously item number four is
self-explanatory if using the updates to
seem to longing for that and then we
move into administration or
administrative matters which is item
number five in our hands it over to
clear to talk us through that report
clear its council a bit all first off
can I apologize to councillors that we
are certainly learning how to build a an
agenda when everybody is remote and so
there have been a couple of hiccups the
first is that you should really be aware
that we picked up the wrong statement of
intent from the South Museum and Art
Gallery and that's been corrected the
second is that in this report there was
actually an additional recommendation
which has got dropped off it's referred
to an appendix to but it was in relation
to the way in which council conducts as
business in the frequency of these
meetings so turning to the report the
first recommendation is that you receive
the report the second is that you
received the minutes of the
Infrastructure Committee meeting it's
minutes very much I've laid at the point
a little bit but it's deliberate on my
part in 50 years from now when we are
seeking to look back we look to Council
for the acceptance in the receipt of
minutes so I don't believe that
committee minutes should actually be
presented to this committee it is a
committee of Council but it is not the
council there is nothing to stop you
receiving those committee minutes which
is why this particular one is here today
but that's an explanation as to why not
all committeeman
so here today I've pulled the
Infrastructure Committee minutes out
specifically because there are some
actions in there that were
recommendations to counsel that the
staff would like to proceed with during
the slock down period and you'll see
them in front of you that you adopt the
amended Elizabeth Park management plan
that you are mended to allow the
development of a BMX facility which will
be at the BMX clubs cost the third
recommendation on that report is that
you appoint an elected member to replace
council Park who has resigned from Wes
net and I think that's self-explanatory
and in appendix 2 of tab 5 you will see
a calendar that proposes that for the
month of May you have weekly committee
of council meetings at 3 o'clock there
is on the basis that a we remain in
alert levels 3 or higher and be that it
is easier to schedule meetings and
cancel them then to not schedule them
and require them to come an update
notice and as that note says we've
advertised or previously advertised
scheduled meetings is cancelled and we
would now get on and just advertise that
they will be weekly committee of council
meetings to deal with all business happy
to answer any questions thank you sorry
you worship just clear I was still mana
reproach me well up to councillors and
said the amount weekly meetings and I
didn't have any objection to it but it
wasn't something I was advocating so
penny counts was beyond that I don't
know maybe fortnightly would suffice
speaker will say so now thank you your
worship
and what I'd like to do if I can has
just moved that we received the
administrative meters first so I'll move
it
that we received the report first sorry
the CQ accounts are so pen
recommendation as well great I'm
actually gonna hand that recommendation
to Council of Pottenger is the chair of
infrastructure I think it's important
that he leads that off I mean when we
get to a peanuts to your worship I'll
lead it up with your suggestion around
the meeting times and dates so all those
in favor which we received the report
please raise your right hand
all those against right Kerry just so
I'll move to Council of pottinger and
regards to his committee infrastructure
to receive being confirm those minutes
any moves those recommendations yes I
would like to move those recommendations
from the last held infrastructure
meeting as listed on boardwalks I'll
second that
Sikandar muted Tony would you like me to
put that motion counts upon injure or
are you happy to do that
yeah you need to put on this chair yeah
thank you
and so I'll put that motion forward all
those in favor raise your right hand
pin give us a wave against all those
against great deck motions moved thank
you um I mean we'll move to his worship
suggestion in relation to appendix true
in regards to the meeting times and I
see councillor Clark had a question
regards to their my view is that we have
meeting weekly meetings on a thirst
anywhere we catch up with clear and and
the senior staff say no no we need
actually have two meetings given that
it's not not typically a full council
meeting and we can't as clear suggest
have put anything through this meeting
from the community
and thank you cats on their plaque clear
I see you want to respond to their night
please frozen so I'm not sure what's
happened here counselor a Manston in
counselor Pottinger him begins up I'm
just wondering with the weekly meetings
as to help move things along because the
longer time we have between meetings a
longer time we can the staff have to
wait before they can action things so is
it so that things can move along that
we're having weekly ones I'm assuming
that CLE can answer that question but
I'm not sure if she's with us or she's
still frozen no I'm with you springing
on my back so any freezing is being
taken out there's a couple of things the
first is that we do have a period of
time to make up for that I think it
would be useful to keep that momentum
going now that we are back into the
swing or something I just want to make
sure that councils understand that this
committee of council has all delegated
authorities of council and the six
matters explicitly referred to in the
Local Government Act and it does replace
the other committee is meeting in
relation to any question about ketchups
and so to use the wording that you madam
chair bring at times if you want to
bring something to the table it needs to
be in a formal meeting because a catch
up cannot make decisions hints the
suggestion of weekly I know that already
there are at least three items for the
agenda next week I recognize that
keeping weekly may be demanding and it
may be possible to cancel but I was just
suggesting it's easier to schedule and
then cancel them the other way around
thank you clear I see councillor
Pottenger had a question then I moved to
councillor Soper thanks Tony liquor was
the lines when clear and introduce this
topic that it's easier to have the
meeting scheduled and then maybe not
have them if not needed but I mean there
shouldn't be any excuse for busyness any
elected member at this time not to be
able to attend anything so I would
sooner have them locked and loaded
along with the ketchups and and if need
be one gets dropped if if that's the
case but you know you've got to have
them in the schedule according to our
where laws written down for meetings so
I'm totally good with it every week
Thank You councillor potting Jay anyone
else here's a question or comment sorry
counselor circle yeah I'm I'm very happy
with the weekly meetings especially as I
had assumed that meant they would be
formal ended Thursday ones are only
catch ups and therefore informal so I'm
very happy that we have them and as
weekly I think that's far too important
first time that we keep that momentum
going and we do indeed find that it's
more than we need they are easier to
count pencil than they are to sit and
the near pop nearness I'm very happy to
seek them weekly Thank You councillor
Soper anyone else to add to it if not I
am happy to put a recommendation to the
table that we propose or adopt the
proposed meeting calendar schedule for
the committee of Council
so April in May if anyone is happy to
move that recommendation will seeking
that recommendation sorry I'll do that
I thinks councillors so pick out some
like it here's a question so I just see
him this oh sorry sorry counsel here
thank you so much
moved by Councillor sofa cap seconded by
councillor kit is it okay all right any
further discussion or questions around
me
right all those in favor please raise
your right hand
all those against grates motion carries
thank you team so then we'll move to if
we can the appointment of a city
councilor or we can elect a member to
replace counselor Clark is the anyone
out there who is interested in this
particular position and if so could you
indicate by raising your hand in talking
to this okay such a yeah all right okay
I'm not sure what we do in the SEC is
anyone that you would like to nominate
counselor Crickett is the chair I think
it's important that you clarify for us
what the role consists of considering
our history with placing it in the fact
that we will ensure time resolve those
issues so it might be appropriate that
you give us a wee description of the
committee and the responsibilities and
it may change some people's minds
absolutely thank you
it's going forward obviously with the
completion of the current recycling
processing contract because the
relationship that we still have with our
partners at waste nip and other
responsibilities with the info and
transportation and such right is
actually like really positive so
although it might seem like a daunting
task
it isn't activities that we are
continuing with Thank You councillor
Clark I see there is a hand up from
council and Ludlow so I'll go councillor
Ludlow and mean councillor Soper
question for councillor crack at times
of meetings wait sorry they have been at
one o'clock me out
and we've also had some in the morning
but it's not at the moment that's not
really movable should it need to be I
guess yeah I think he's council Cricket
Council a sofa
thank you I was going to say I would be
interested but he have an obvious reason
why we have to declare conflicts of
interest on a number of occasions at the
moment and I was going to ask councillor
Ludlow a councillor Ludlow was
interested and being nominated sorry how
might I switch my microphone on yes I
have here we go
year provided we were able to meet
mornings I could I could accommodate
that typically when we are back in our
usual chambers and meetings have been in
the morning so thank you that's another
thank you I see mr. cute councillor Kate
here's a question so I was just a second
hearse nomination it was all beautiful
I did sorry I was just trying to unmute
my yeah yeah so we've had a
recommendation to nominate councillor
Ludlow
moved by Councillor sofa seconded by
Councillor heat all those in favor of
capsular Ludlow taking their appointment
of I guess council elected
representative on waist knit and place
of councillor clap please raise your
right hands all those against right all
right thank you - it's wonderful
um okay so we move to item number six on
the agenda which is the principles of
the infrastructure strategy again I'm
going to hem the
- counselor Pottinger but before I count
him Nick - counselor Pottenger Jeremy
Ray's welcome to our meeting
Jeremy is the engineering services
manager in he will speak to the report
for us should a Jimmy River humor
tell me somewhere I I think Jane was
going to cap that off so I let Jane take
it off my apologies Jane thank you
that's all right Thank You counselor
Biddle now Jeremy did all the work and
wrote the report but he's part of my
team so I just like to make a few
introductory comments and they hand over
to Jeremy and counselors for questions
so just some high-level comments the the
infrastructure strategy is a statutory
requirement and it works together with
the financial strategy to underpin the
LTP and covers about thirty years you
may well know all this but just as a
little reminder you'll see sent out on
the report the principles and strategies
which are appropriate to guide your plan
and the associated asset management
plans and probably of lost note is we're
planning to build on the existing
infrastructure strategy and s8
management plans and simply update them
and we'll bring them back to you at a
workshop in June so other than that
that's all I wanted to say to set the
scene I think please direct all the
difficult questions to Jeremy and Jeremy
I think I've covered most of what we
wanted to highlight that right good
thank you
I guess yeah any any questions on that
um I won't try to labor through too much
of it for you any questions counsel
appalling sure and then council o'clock
thanks I note that it states that and
this is good that we don't intend to
expand
infrastructure at our own cost and this
is obviously referring to subdivisions
and stuff like that now previously
assisting that I think we've we have
infrastructure saying this and yet a
regulatory department and previously
what what I have observed have gone
ahead and allowed subdivisions but at
our cost now I'm not sure due to both
departments sort of align themselves
well how does that work
think that a lot of that comes down to
we're not trying to extend the network
to service new eeriest and as part of my
role I'm also undertaking the
development engineer role to some degree
in trying to integrate what we're doing
better with planning and that really
comes down to it those at the time of
consent that we make sure that the
applications are not costing council the
applicant has got appropriate conditions
and as part of their consent to cover in
infrastructure so yeah that's good
adjust that obviously and and one of the
recent examples that has crept up on us
is people wanting their roads sealed
because of too much traffic and now the
only reason there's too much traffic is
because a mess of subdivision on
someone's lifestyle block or farm there
used to be three people down a road now
there's 23 people and the pressure comes
on Council to to have that road paved or
tar sealed or something so this gets you
know if these rules are put in place and
or Garant through all the departments
would be really really good if you
cancel appalling chair and I'm assuming
if you just want to give me a wave that
you questions been answered excellent
thank you and
and councillor Clark had a question
thank you here Jerry
there with my lack of knowledge on this
but I noticed in some of the
infrastructure work that's done by some
other councils that they have a a sort
of a local rating system built into
their strategy which said basically in
Layton says that if you're tendering out
work or for a project that there is a
differential and I think always got a
tempting differential for local firms so
what it does is it it sort of sustains
local businesses they have maybe that
the multinationals on the intern the
larger companies didn't like coming from
out of district I wonder where that
certainly a strategy or whether it's
something that we have and some other
policy around procurement I could just
interject that that's the procurement
policy with it yeah and it is there okay
thank you thank you very much as the any
further questions on this particular
report of either Jane or Jeremy great is
the anyone who would be happy to move
those recommendations that the report
principles of infrastructure strategy be
received yeah I'll move that Thank You
councillor Bollinger yeah in Thank You
councillor Lewis you can toast you can
debate report any further discussion or
questions on it great all those in favor
if you just give me a wave here against
Kerry next time moving to item number
seven of and ginger which is the
suspension of solid mice final which
we're all aware has being done I'll hand
it to clear for a quick conversation
around this report if you count to the
boodle I'm happy to take the reporter's
read answer any questions I'm happy to
move
because it's um it speaks for itself and
that has already happened it's only a
confirmation thank you very much so that
report in the recommendations being
moved by Councillor sofas you can did by
counsel there ever any questions and
discussion around me all those in favor
raise your right pizza against carries
thank you
I mean we move into our statement of
intent so I've got the first one which
is item number eight in the cable city
holding to the limited statement of
intent in our last Dave foster to speak
to that report surely David you're a
look at statement of intent is attached
look it's it's a good statement of
intent quite significantly improved on
on prior years although last year was a
big step forward to it covers very well
all of the operations are going on in
the subsidiaries main point I guess in
terms of it is the dividend distribution
it states at a four point eight which is
actually the amount we've we've already
budgeted one of the things that is good
is that it it reflects a level of
dividend that is rising with their
expected inflation rate so thank you
Dave are questions I've got councilor
Lewis councillor Soper I have no
questions tony is going to move it
because I thought was pretty
self-explanatory
thank you I have no questions either and
I was going to sit because I also plan
tree and it's they conceded an
improvement on some past ones
thank you capsule asopa so I have a
recommendation on the table which you
will have all read under the report
moved by capsule that Louis seconded by
Councillor so pear I see a question from
councillor Pottenger
okay it states in the SOI that at least
every 12 months months there is a you
know meeting between the shareholder and
whole Co so when do we have that the
other day with the briefing by Brian
wood or was that quite an informal was
it or are we table we're going to have a
sort of formal meeting withhold code to
you know talk about things and ask
questions I think you you want to have a
and we're trying to get into place a a
mix of formal versus informal the one
that the SOI is referring to will be the
AGM so that's the one effectively where
they host and other ones who drive the
agenda of that meeting there are also
meetings in play that we drive the
agenda of where we get them along to the
council meeting to effectively good and
updates to the council's
right who triggers that or what's the
process for that one day we we trigger
that and it's some I'm trying to think
what that's half yearly or quarterly
certainly it will be at least half
yearly and I think we were getting into
the program of having them come along on
a quarterly basis to give us an update
totally because we do our reporting on
bases right so that's a two-way sort of
dialogue and the meeting rather than the
AGM yes the AGM as they as they drive
their agenda it's on their turf so to
speak yeah where where they get in
control of that meeting as opposed to
the other ones where we're in control of
the meeting in the agenda so just would
you know off the top of your head when
the next one maybe would have few months
away or no I don't we'll we'll look to
schedule at once once weird once we're
back in out of the out of the code yep
cool that's good
thanks Thank You Council upon a
counselor I bet or have I missed someone
ring yeah I'm pretty sure that that's to
him under the previous administration
that
was actually said make three monthly and
an informal basis just as knowledge to
the council yes I think there could be
right in the old days they used to ask
when I wasn't available and then Thank
You counsel appalling chair I'll move to
Council they're safer I'm sorry you're
on mute I was just going to concur that
my memory was that we had decided it
would be quarterly but the code but
nineteen crisis had upset that and that
I would think it would be reasonably
straightforward to get it back on track
when we were in the position to do that
but my memory was certainly that we had
said it would be good to do quarterly
thank you very much so I take that lead
that we are looking for a meeting to to
happen mr. foster Whedon we can come out
of lockdown and have the ability to do
so
from what I'm feeling from the table and
I think we've got a council clerk with a
question is it right counselor cluck did
you yeah thank you
yeah Dave don't I don't have any issues
or just just one minor one and when the
listings not there on page 27 above
where it's got performance targets
you've got a heading that's number Carol
City probably get a property limited and
it talks here about hwc P Management
Limited hold the balance of land
acquired and I see it continues to work
with Holcombe and the City Council and
I'm just wondering what the benefit is
of actually keeping the property company
in place do we actually need it for the
benefit of managing their that land
balance that we've got or is there
something that somebody on the track
might not be away from the structure I
think it's probably worth having that
discussion once ICL is properly formed
in there and the transfer as a kid and
at that point they're still only bhw CP
and I think at that point when we know
what that is are we worth tuning our
- whether that land actually gets
transferred to something else I think a
good thing about it is at the moment it
sort of keeps it separate it keeps it
clear and keeps it probably sort of
boxed up into a section but it's worth a
while once the rest of the land is done
to determine whether there I see P l HW
CP structure and thus ownership is going
to be worthwhile keeping in place into
the future yeah thank you
you need to take your mute off Tony
sorry my apologies um any further
discussion on that report so the
recommendations that we received the
report and that council provides a no
specific comment for changes to the
statement of intent and if I gotta move
over there
Thank You councillor Louis in seeking
good counselor Clark all those in favor
waive your right hands all those against
motion carries thank you my me I'm just
gonna cheat that you can hear all of us
nailed and clear probably a bit too late
now but I'm assuming like me you can
hear all of it it's okay and thank you
thank you um I think we have item number
nine which is the indicator city
charitable trust statement of intent
thank this is yours again it's a fairly
short statement of intent significantly
improved on last year last year's was a
little bit of a jumble
they put quite a lot of work into this
it's much clearer the main issue in this
one is the an issue that council has
considered in its own right which is
actually the ownership of the Rugby Park
and whether Rugby Park should continue
to be an ICCT
asset that's really a thing for the
council to determine over the next year
or so and you'll be aware that we've
commissioned some tax advice in terms of
that because it could trigger quite a
significant taxation cost in doing the
transfer back to us and we need to know
that before we do the paper up to the
council in terms of the recommendation
so I've got no I don't think there's any
comments we should be making back thank
you Thank You councillor cipher any
questions around there and I do have a
question
Dave and I think that it's probably fear
that I disclose that I had spoken to LCE
about this earlier so under governance
on page 40 of the statement of intent it
sees that there are to ensure that trust
ensures all of its trustees in executive
offices against liabilities to other
parties that may rise from their
positions now on this particular board
we have counselors and our chief
executive is a trustee my concern was
that because our chief executive runs
the administrative part of of this
committee they in fact she should be
replaced or thee sorry chief executive
whoever holds that position should
actually be replaced by someone in
governance I don't believe that our
chief executive has an issue with it and
I'm wondering if we could have that
change with a Miss oh I before its
adopters if possible you know I'm just
opening any discussion for there is I'm
not sure if that can be done I think if
I can a it's not an insurance issue it's
a very good question it's not though a
statement of intent issue because I
would imagine that would be something
that's established under the foundation
document for the trust
usually a trust like this determines who
the members will be so you would
actually need to go back to the
settlement deed of the trust and that
can be quite a complicated legal process
to go and get a settlement of a trust I
mean we're looking to it thank you very
much I'd appreciate their counsel s okay
I was just going to say on that I think
you'll find the appointments were
confirmed in the mirror list of
appointments at the beginning of the
tomb so again you might have to do a wee
bit more research on that it's it's not
a statement of intent oh sorry
the appointments aren't good enough
citement of the temple is such Thank You
cancellous open thank you David what's
it to your attention anyway so that's a
good start I think counsel o'clock had
raised it earlier on and we just wanted
to ensure that we could move it
discussion forward a bit more and so
thank you for that I'm hearing and I
don't know why crickets or someone's got
something in their background so I'm
just going to ask everybody to ensure
that if they're not speaking the mute it
may be my ears
well my speakers I think it's mine
is it okay thank you mister interesting
okay so back to our business there's a
report here in recommendations to be a
doctor do I have a mover for those Oh
Thank You councillor Abbott in ic record
cuts the clock has raised his hand to
seek in those any further discussion or
questions on those Thanks please raise
your right hand all in favor against
just lay low did you raise your hand
series only to second the motion
that's right thank you time all done so
that's all past no we moved to the south
of Museum and artillery trust statement
of intent and because I cheer the Smeg
Trust Board I'm going to ask that any
questions be directed to the deputy
because I'm cheering this meeting today
so Darren will lead us off after a day
foster his spoken to this report thank
you Dave
here come the crickets back stopped
being really straightforward it meets
their requirements that you'd expect
from a statement of intent
I guess the again crickets are gone and
Jeff is frozen no he's back okay which
is effectively the ongoing governance as
the major issues we know that well so in
the mix that I don't think there's
really much for us to feed back to swag
in regards to this statement of intent
unless counselors had some particular
issues thank you Dave
so I'll just open the floor for
questions in all allow derringer to take
their counsel appalling J counsel aside
pair in counselor Clerk well thanks my
question is regarding a statement that
occurs and paragraph one point five
financial assumptions
it states that Smeg owned the building I
thought we had that sort of clarified
that Smeg don't own the building ICC
does I guess clarify that that's that's
not untrue the trust board is still just
waiting to formally satisfy itself okay
so can we receive it in this format
because if we mor adopt it or what are
we doing with it yes because it's easy
enough to amend a statement of intent I
mean for the ones that were produced in
recent years because we've had the the
renovation projects sitting in the
background there's been a lot of
assumptions that are just around
business as usual this is is quite
adequate bearing in mind that
everything's in a state of flux over
ownership of the building governance
structure and redevelopment projects so
it's
ed suits it's it's our needs at this
point and by that means needs I mean
councils so is there some dispute can I
take it there is some dispute over
whether council does own it as or is
that been accepted I wouldn't call it a
dispute the trustees just query durand
and asked for some some reassurance
around it so we hadn't had a chance to
meet since that question was last asked
Dave we found we've been looking through
the Smeg financial statements actually
have the building within their financial
statements and my staff about that
that's an issue what needs to be worked
through that doesn't necessarily denote
ownership but what it does the note is
what accountant works on for those
issues as a thing called control and so
because the trust to all intents and
purposes has controlled the building in
terms of access maintenance who's doing
what what's happening in it it has been
accounted for as their asset
it doesn't denote ownership or non
ownership and of course the issue of
ownership has only come up from memory
within the last six months I think up
until now everybody believed that Smeg
was the building owner which as I say
could be confused with control versus
ownership but possibly worth just noting
in terms of getting back to them in
regards to that question I'm sorry I was
just checking sorry to confuse everybody
I hate councillor Soper wanting to ask a
question was there anybody else thank
you any councillor Clark sorry Jerry
so sorry Tony all I was going to say is
that will feed the reflection back and
the the trust board can amend the
statement of
Thank You Darren councillor Sokka mine
wasn't a question I raised my hand when
the didn't set free any other questions
to move so councillor class got a
question I'll leave move and get all
that questions been asked and answered
cats let's open council o'clock yeah
just a couple of quick issues
Rhaenys already covered the issue of
ownership which I wasn't comfortable
with because I think it denotes position
that we would not be happy with but on
two other quick issues just a bit of an
update for me is where do you see that
the future of the museum going how do
you see the museum as being another car
walled city museum and the collection I
guess one of their words being a more of
a self and wide thing that wouldn't be
covered by snake see happy to answer
that
I guess that what's being set up and
proposed by into Carroll city is that it
would be a council asset but yes that
the collection is as a regional one and
there's already the regional committee
established and it can become the
guardian of the collection so short
answer your question is use and council
need to move the recommendation think
she canceled ahsoka I appreciate you
joining amber on my behalf councillor
Ludlow and would be happy to just remind
everyone that council his adopted that
recommendation for the governance to go
to consultation and I just have a
question around when that would likely
to happen of either clear or Dave
now with Kovich maybe shared the
original intent was that the
concentration would take place as part
of the annual plan you
seek that advice at the same time as you
received advice that it wasn't legally
necessary we will look at that
positioning come back to Council
thank you clear would appreciate that
counselor Clark just a second a second
issue for you Darren
if city is taking over the long term
ownership on its own vertical City
Museum that we're heading towards and
snag has ownership of the collection
which I hear what you're saying on that
does that mean that we'll get some swag
buy-in and some buy-in from the Alec to
councils
when it comes to the storage facility
smegal really support the storage
facility and I guess we stand alone
alongside Invercargill City and
advocating for it to the other councils
thank you everybody so that motion the
draft statement of intent for Seattle
museum at gallery gallery be received by
council so that council provides a no
specific comment for changes that may
need to be amended in regards to the
ownership of the building which council
at Ludlow has sued that he would take
back to our committee and we will wait
we have requested that information from
clear and we will do so in writing from
Smeg perspective to the chief executive
to get that ownership issue finalized so
with that in mind the motions being
moved it recommendations have been moved
and seconded all those in favor raise
right and all those against carries
excellent thank you
so moving now to the brakes a statement
of intent ed I'll pass you turian and
qre in it
nice to see you Chiara Thank You chair
Kira councillors so yeah I will take the
report as read and noting the effect
that Cove in 19 has had on the operation
of great South and they need to focus
refocus their statement of intent they
report includes the amended process I
will just move to the section funding
breakdown where I've put a proposal for
your discussion and consideration in
terms of the indication that counsel
wishes to make to great south as to
where they would like their focus to be
and so I have proposed a new funding
breakdown which you can see within the
table proposing a reduction of fifty
thousand from the 2019 2020 period in
the area of Regional Economic
Development an increase in a hundred
thousand in the area of business
development which includes the business
support work which I'm great south of
indicated as a big priority at the
moment in their response to covert 19
I'm proposing a 50,000 reduction in the
tourism development budget an increase
in 50,000 in the events delivery budget
and a reduction in the regional
well-being to the 50,000 to allow for
that support for housing as discussed at
the earlier meeting in January and so
just to summarize those recommendations
is to enable greater South the
flexibility to respond to the covert 19
situation and to help with the restart
process and working with businesses to
overcome this unique challenge so it
reflects that importance of increased
business support and the support that
council wants to make sure is available
to those people that may be affected by
unemployment and and it also recommends
a focus on the city center and on events
to enable that restart for domestic
tourism you'll see I am still
recommending a small reduction in the
tourism budget and this is to reflect
the fact that that cannot continue or
restart until level one and it's likely
that may take considerable period of
time and it's important to be aware that
those areas of the country that have
previous
we've been largely focused on
international tourism will be refocusing
on domestic and so hence the
recommendation that Invercargill really
focus on getting the city center restart
focused around events thank you Rhiannon
councillors I know that we had an
excellent workshop around this and
there's a lot of discussions I welcome
that discussion to the table and
encourage you to yes speak to this
particular topic obviously covered and
the impact on our community is going to
be huge great south will be predominant
very critical in that recovery so where
we put our money in suggests that they
focus on during this recovery time is
going to be critical councillors I've
got councillor Clark anyone else wanting
to ask any questions about this okay cut
to the Clark and then I've just got one
as well thank you Rhiannon yeah yeah I'm
done don't disagree with there I think
it's an excellent reshaping of the money
an interesting comment from tourism New
Zealand chief executive in the last 24
hours
he said nationally the tourism industry
is 40 billion dollars but of that 40
billion only seventeen billion is
actually overseas that 23 is actually
internal so what you were saying there
before about needing to pick up on
encouraging internal people to come
south and part of that will be the maybe
the events that we can get into the city
and certainly into the stadium is a good
look for me
the external stuff will be delivered by
factors play outside our pay grade or
the so all that good reflection from
tourism that more than half our tourism
dollars actually are from internal
movements I think
go for it Rhiannon sorry just to agree
that's absolutely correct I think that
what is important to be a just to be
aware of in that restart of the domestic
tourism is that the indications we've
had from economists is that that markets
not likely to bounce up to exactly the
same level it was before and there will
be increased competition for those
domestic tourists because of the markets
that have been largely international and
focused before obviously we have Queen
Sun on our doorstep
we'll be competing for those same
tourists so that's just that response
just just just to add to that Rhiannon
the other thing that the tourism New
Zealand chief executive said was the
fact that we don't sometimes catch is
that we as New Zealanders spend about
nine billion dollars a year travelling
overseas and while people might be a
little bit careful with a discretionary
money there might be a pot of gold that
people will start to turn inwards as
opposed to outwards so I thought that
was an interesting reflection as well
include councillor cleric councillor so
per inning councillor keet thank you
it's not so much a question as just the
comment that I think it's a very
critical refocus or their contract
funding monies and I think the thick
that we have noted the need for great
self but maintain flexibility and it's
not unusual that unknown vectors that
are obviously going to be with us for
quite some time there's an important
part of it
refocus and the fact that we've also
noted that we would want to be informed
of any budget changes require the heat
of those changes being made so I think
it's a it's a good practical refocus but
also providing for the flexibility that
great self is going to me so I'm quite
comfortable with where things are at the
moment and I also know the core funding
is being maintained but scrapes out the
great deal of security and that core
funding thank you that's a kid
yeah just Nobby what were those figures
and there was a bit of noise here and I
didn't pick up how much the jurist been
going
overseas in internally okay three three
bits of information our our tourism
industry which is what comes in and
moves around the country is 40 billion
seventeen billion is external people
coming into our country and the other
twenty three is Kiwis moving around our
country and the fire the last factor was
as New Zealanders we spend nine billion
a year going overseas now some of that
will be tourism and some of that will be
I guess people going for commercial
reasons but that's a big chunk that's no
longer going so that some of that might
be redirected back into internal yeah
and taking that on board I hear a lot of
other areas in New Zealand I dealing up
to attack live the citizens of New
Zealand to travel to the area I heard
them talking about it on used to talks
he had been the other night do you feel
that amount of money that we've put
aside to attract people here isn't that
the other thing that came out in the
article was another thing I thought was
interesting and it was a more of a
peripheral one and what they said was
once we get out of lockdown the country
is out of lockdown our borders are open
a lot of conferences that might have
been held in places overseas may very
well be held here because people will
see this as a very safe place to come to
so yeah I don't think the what's in the
great self budget is necessarily going
to generate the tourism coming here but
it's just a over arching against
mechanism allows us to focus on what we
can to encourage it thank you chance for
cut does they answer your question
counselor kids yeah almost almost thank
you do you want to try again the more we
spend the more money we will attract to
our region it's all about retail and
I've been in town most of my working
life and it does work if you do it
correctly will benefit by it if we
benefit sure Thailand will benefit
feeling will be anything
got to work together and work very hard
a great Thank You counsel acute my
question was have already asked so
that's okay thank you
counts my Clark for doing that so we'll
move now to the recommendations or back
to the recommendations knowing that the
budget breakdown is what we looking it
into the direction that we're giving
great self to move forward the only
other question I had sorry Rhiannon was
around the events a hundred thousand
dollars it's not a lot of money and I
can't see a lot of events are happening
in the next few months anyway
is there going to be sufficient for the
financial year um so the recommendation
is to increase the funding by fifty
thousand to reflect that conversation
that councils been having around the
importance of events and it is of course
not a huge amount of money when you when
you take it into account but in terms of
proportion I think it's a about I would
recommend at this point perfect thank
you so anyone here Peter moves those
recommendations on this report I'll make
em oh sorry captain Lewis Heather's
cleaned up here sorry in seconded by
Councillor Soper all those are any
further discussion and Christians all
those in favor raise your right hand
I know you're getting sick of raising
your hands but I've got to save them
it's thank you against great carrying us
and now you worship you've been pretty
quiet so I'm just gonna check it with
you to see if you wanted to add anything
and here before we moved to the next
part of the meeting um well there's a
few bits and pieces one was a typo and I
hate raising issues over tired eyes but
we had kept to the signal model group
others for a long time and there's a
print a always fondant
at least as a typos and mine was the
word meeting should be replaced too
weird member and that's my one on page
[Applause]
page three and just I'm not sure what
happened there but on the committee of
council it said we would consist of a
quorum of seven and two members must be
physically prison and then it was said
however this was replaced by Kovac 19
response legislation act 2020 which
provides for a member of a local
authority has the right to attend any
meetings by means of an audio or
audio-visual link and I wondered what
change it occurred between those two
positions and does that mean anyone can
plug into us and listen to our whole
discussion or is that just another it's
a word missing some way your worship I'm
wondering if I could get some
clarification from clear around that is
it possible please clear thanks little I
think his worship is referring to the
fact that at councils last meeting and I
believe that date was the 24th of March
an aware of whether the government would
change the legislation council took the
only speed but could to keep operating
and that was that it established a new
committee the committee of council it
delegated
all authorities of council by the six in
the act and a step of the deputy mayor
as the chair of that committee of
council and it worked on the basis that
the law as it stood on the 24th of March
said that any committee of council can
have a quorum as small as two members
and so what we they and the Kabul city
council did was said we will establish a
committee where everyone is a member and
two members will need to be in the
building so to speak because that was
the only option available to us at the
time that council met on the 24th of
March after that meeting and I think it
was about the 26th of March the
government introduced some emergency
legislation into the house and overrode
the what I'll call the usual provisions
on the act and said that all meetings
could be by videoconference those
provisions only last for the terms of
the pandemic and the government also
said whilst we like your public meetings
to be available to all members of the
public we understand that zoom makes
that harder and so we will allow you to
have your meeting and then upload it to
the to your website afterwards so that
public scrutiny as possible so the
report that you are referring to your
worship is acknowledging how we started
on a 24th of March and what changed
during that small period and the fact
that we are now giving you feet to the
committee of council that council
established but we are not requiring any
elected members to go into the building
because the government has asked that we
are ever possible you don't
just a little quickie as you a person
over three of us I think on the council
and if you're over 70 particular
attention has been gone to your
vulnerability and it's just a really
good article well I'll post it out to
you by an 85 year old woman who's very
strong feminist and it's decided to
reject this notion that you're more
vulnerable and once you did see what
they so oh it's the only one that I've
seen that's brave and I was challenged
in the Prime Minister's announcement but
saying well there it's a free speech and
they were there thank you your worship I
am expected to hear something like that
from you a lot sooner than now so it
doesn't surprise me that you've got the
article and I look forward to receiving
it was any questions around his worships
information that he'd okay perfect and
so with that we will move to the rates
postponement in remissions policy so
again councillors we've had a very
constructive workshop together in fact
that constructive it was about three
hours long so it was a very informative
good discussion throughout the workshop
but I welcome that discussion back to
the table today you see the report and
there has been a bit of misunderstanding
that we were going to strike the rates
today and but there is not the fact
today is about the rates postponement in
remissions policy as you all know like
we do every year we must adopt the
annual plan before we strike the rates
so it's important that we go through the
process is we would every year and
welcome discussion and debate around
this particular policy I take it that
it's all being read so
if you're happy to speak to that I'd go
for it
councillor Clark sure just on the issue
of the rates it was my understanding
when we had the workshop early April
that time framing was that we would have
a workshop on the 20th and then later in
the month on the 28th we would strike
the rates and so I'm happy to be guided
on what we shouldn't shouldn't be doing
but I find it a little bit hard to
fathom that places like SDC as already
announced last week what their rates are
going to be prior to that queenstown
lake district of announced what they're
going to do and whether the formal
mechanism might not be till i get the
approval of the engine plan might be
fine but i think i think members of the
community are wanting a bit of a steer
on us about what our rates are going to
be and so it would be my preference that
we that we do something about the figure
that we came to in the figure that we
came to in the woods Thank You
councillor a plaque
I just want to ask everybody to mute if
they're not already muted like we can
hear background speakers in their
conversation so I'm just a reminder to
please mute yourself if you haven't
already councillor Clark your question I
is it is mr. foster here to speak today
don't you know still on mute do you want
me to do
like where to do and speak you speak I'm
happy to lead out counselor battle it
may be that mr. foster would then like
to add to anything I'd say and I'll just
start by closing the doors so that the
noise of the rest of the householders
interfere the discussion that was held
with counselors at the beginning of the
month was about the possibility of
putting a resolution in relation to a
particular rates increase and they're
being moved
Chancellor Clark was correct for having
a workshop and then a formal meeting on
the 28th of April however at no stage
was there a suggestion of the rates
being strike and if councillor Clark is
referring to the fact that some councils
have given a clear signal as toward the
sort of increase the can't be are going
to see this year the constituents are
going to see this year then that could
be brought to a council meeting for you
to have that discussion for money
because we come back to that discussion
that we had at the beginning of a
meeting about discussions versus
decisions the annual plan itself is not
yet ready for adoption and bad as when
you do get the rate increase if council
would like to consider the rate increase
to end give a signal to its community
then I believe mr. foster would suggest
that within two to three weeks would be
possible to give that indication without
giving the without having the adoption
the annual plan Rhiannon's still with us
and I was talking to Rhiannon this
morning we are proposing the adoption
early in June because we think it's good
to get it out of the way if we can but I
would just count some counselors that
there is a difference between a media
statement about the likely or indicative
rates increase this is the formally
resolved increase that councils consider
at a meeting when they consider annual
budget
in cue clear I'm just wanting to ask
counsel as if they have any questions
around that I see counsel o'clock his
hand up and I'll get to you in a second
but I just want to ensure that everyone
has an opportunity to speak and so
counsel o'clock in then counsel
appalling Jerr thank you
yeah sure well I I listened with great
intent and what Dave put up at the last
meeting we had which was the 20th and I
thought that was really impressive and
and you know you all know that I've been
an advocate for zero rates for a long
time and but based on what the advice he
gave me which was a lot of ways quite a
large over picture of what we were
facing in New Zealand and some
background information I thought his
suggestion of 2% was a a good point to
be going forward with and I moved my
position on that and I I don't I'm not
too worried about what Claire had to say
about an indicative indication or a
formal decision it would seem from what
we had out of the workshop the other day
that all of us had a pretty uniform
agreement that 2% was a good benchmark
to go to and that's not likely to change
in the next three four five or six weeks
so why don't we just give them an
indication and even if it's worded an
addictive melody to just say that this
is what we're looking towards because
it's unlikely to change you can't slip
Claire councillor Soper
can you just mute to yourself counselor
sofa but unmute sorry at the moment I
just want to make the observation that
counsel does not make decisions and
workshops and I would never like to give
the impression to the puppet that we do
and that it may be that if mr. mr.
Foster is indicating that two weeks from
now we could discuss at a formal council
meeting in and decorative right the in I
would be comfortable that that was what
we did but I don't know that this
discussion should go any further today
with any indication that Council make
decisions and workshops Thank You
councillor Soper and anyone else would
anyone else like to speak to that
councillor Pottinger mine's not in
regards to the rights increase it's
actually to do with the item that we're
discussing policy
so back when we first discussed
discussed this policy ahead a 30%
reduction in income as one of the
criteria its and paragraph 1.2 and I
suggested that we change it to 20% that
seems to be a lot of wage sort of
decreases of whatever but what um I mean
I hate changing the mine like this but I
just want to throw it out there reading
in in the media about what Gore put
forward was the criteria for
postponement was financial hardship
Judah Cove at 19 now I'm just wondering
and it's purely up for discussion this
financial hardship just a more general
easier to becomes to come to grips with
then putting in a percentage value I
just to me it sounded quite good the way
the Gord where did it financial hardship
caused by the pandemic now I'm just
asking people to they're like the 20% or
Gazeta said uneasy you want to get your
head around I think he can't sleep lack
and I've got pains going up so I hear
counsel that Arnold Ludlow in mean clack
who's first you suffer hardship jewelry
is a loss of income and I think it's
rather than sort of it's easier to prove
if you like then sort of look at a big
picture and then sort of make an
assessment as to whether you hear that's
pretty straightforward it just shows
when you turn over last year where you
turn over this year prep say three weeks
in a row to me it's just easier the
numbers the government numbers have been
doing very good I think this is good
good as well yet so I support the 20
machine thanks
yep in the same position I think it's
it's easier we
a more firm indication of what we want
if we were to leave it at fun it
hardship is a result of good result Koba
19 in that sense it's just it's too
subjective and might leave it open to
some people taking advantage of it
thanks Tony
Thank You cancer lab no I think there
was counsel in Lewis or in suruc lat in
Ming Louis
my apologies in my positions huh and
support what ringing raised I think a
percentage can also be can be
manipulated so far I can say husband and
wife living in a house without a
mortgage and the wife gets a drop of 20%
or they combined get drop a person may
well be in a position that's still okay
where another person with a family with
three or four kids it gets a 15% or more
25% depending on the margin is could be
in serious trouble so I I favor the
hardship thing and just allowed to be
assist on a case-by-case basis Thank You
counselor clerk counselor cracker inning
Arnold I actually disagree with
counselor Clark the and the sense that a
20 be seen pertains to a postponement of
right so it's not like someone in the
husband and wife you're just going to
turn around and take advantage of the
situation like as long as it is covering
all bases and there is a quantifiable
number there that we can actually use to
to benchmark against I think that that's
the best outcome otherwise you like
counselor Ludlow said you've got too
much subjectivity it also comes down to
the person who's applying for it as to
what they would define hardship to be
and then that becomes a gray area who's
the person that makes the the judgment
call on whether or not a person is in
hardship or not when it when it doesn't
have a qualified number to it Thank You
counselor cricket so I'm trying to meet
at the same time excuse me counselor
Lewis I'm so sorry I completely missed
you so please ask your question and then
we'll go back to counselor annulled
thank you cancel the story of my life
being missed I'm sorry I think we have
to be very careful to make sure we have
rates of postponements and preference to
rates for admission because there will
be
people out there that will be applying
for rights remission it mean well not be
entitled to it it'd be very hard to do a
financial background check on everybody
but quite a lot of people Nadira say
people who are on a benefit are
struggling in increasing their benefit
and probably the expenses haven't been
extended much over the covert for all of
that there are extra charges of course
for the reasons of groceries and things
but their income has been pretty static
so we've got to be careful people do not
take advantage of the situation for the
sake of it the they have been one or two
things for example they wage subsidy for
large companies it seems to be have been
abused and I say that weird with
quotation marks I'm not putting on for
it but the people it's definitely taking
advantage of the government's leniency
and let us not let people take advantage
of they are apparently didn't see thank
you Thank You councillor Louis
councillor Arnold yeah well I look
through this policy quite closely and I
was actually pretty good policy and just
after hearing councillor Clark's
description of some of the circumstances
that cool dole / Crips the way a person
was deceased
makes me think even more that you need
you just stick to this percentage the
people that are going to be applying for
this they already under stress so the
last thing they need is to really to do
a dissection of their indeed financials
to to to be assessed and judged on this
to whether it suits or not so to me it's
good to have a simple criteria and it's
not just a national thing goes with
people to have them use the system you
can always get systems like that but
generally speaking I think if you talk
to most decent business people which our
most business people they'll think that
the government's been quite good in
their reactions and how they keep it
simple and acted fast and I think by
having a percentage here I think that
we're sort of given that sort of same
message and there's only air some
Catholic rates here this phone man
generally speaking so so you're still
gonna pay the rates it's just you're
going to pay them a little bit later so
I think keep it simple keep it clean
keep it nice I agree with counsel crack
it on this one Thank You counselors I
just have two questions of Dave if I can
and then I see capsule o'clock here's
another question so I will go to council
o'clock after I've asked my questions
but I want to apologize first because I
had intention of sending them through
but early in my day got away on me too
but the first one is I see that the
policy isn't effective immediately and
I'm I'm struggling with why we have to
wait till May to adopt this policy and
I'm struggling that we have to go out
and consult on what we know our
community needs already so that is the
first question and my second question is
in regards to the interests that we're
charging on the postponement and I come
back to what I first raised in our
workshop was why we have to charge
interest at all and I'm struggling with
those two things so I just want to ask
mr. foster to explain please
in answer to the first the rates
postponement policies rates remissions
policies are an element that has covered
in the Local Government Act in the early
100s I think it's about 105 and it's an
element the council may have
postponement policies of may have
remissions policies but where it has a
policy it has to adopt that policy or
change that policy following a
consultation process that fits with
section 82 of the Local Government Act
so section 82 of the Local Government
Act as a consultation process which is a
little bit more flexible and loose
compared to the special consultative
procedure that you need for certain
elements but it does require a period of
consultation so hence we've got a fairly
simple policy we will go
with a formal consultation probably for
about four weeks I think I think the
legislation stipulates about four weeks
so we need to consult on an amendment to
the policy or the adoption of a new
policy so that's the answer to the first
question the second question is that
we're actually looking for the policy to
be reasonably flexible to allow people
to apply and one of the things that
we're thinking about around that is to
get that level of reasonableness in
there needs to be a sort of financial
hurdle which doesn't just say to
everybody look apply for it and so we've
gone up 3.5% because there's no
application fee for it so for our other
postponement policies you may note in
the document there's a there's a fee for
for actioning it this one has no fee
fractional postponements and the
interest rate that set is just slightly
above our cost of funds but also below
the lowest cost of funds for a rate
payer right so basically it's it's there
to stop people it's there to stop
everybody just the citing the postponed
right three year right so there's going
to be some financial cost if you've got
the money
you're not going to postpone okay but if
you haven't then you're going to be
making that judgment it's flexible so
it's going to cost you less than your
mortgage will cost you and so that's a
reason for going with a costume there so
just for some clarification around me
should I want a rates postponement it
would be less for me to pay the interest
to the council then to borrow the money
to pay the rates yes that's why we need
to keep their editable where people
again don't take
advantage would that be fixed the key is
is to stop people taking advantage of
what we're trying to eliminate as the
free lunch view okay so get a whole lot
of free riders who decide I here I might
as well postpone my rates for a year if
it's not gonna cost me anything
whereas what this is is it's a little
bit of a hurdle it's not going to stop
people applying if they need to but it
is going to stop people sitting back
saying it's a free ride that's the
reason for okay my concern I guess is
around like the complet the complexity
of applying for such erratic rates
postponement or remission and I'm just I
would hate to think that we're making it
too hard for people who are desperate at
this time in probably in a position
we've never been before and and that was
my concern so my concern in terms of
writing it that's why we've come up with
the three and a half percent interest
rate because actually had three and a
half percent is and interest rates we
are not going to invest a lot of money
to even test the twenty percent income
loss we will be doing a little bit but
we'll be doing very little bit will
basically be accepting that because they
are costs of funds is cupboard that only
people that are going to apply for the
sort of people who needs to so therefore
it's a hurdle to offset a higher level
of administration for both us and the
applicant okay thank you mr. foster I
appreciate their any further questions
from any council it's canceled the clerk
in the important just going through the
policy I see there on page 65 of their
book it says remission means a rate that
is not paid by the rate payer and is
paid by counsel on behalf of the right
path the right earth debt is written off
as I go forward in the policy I don't
see any criteria
our mission of rates it all talks about
postponement of rates or have I missed
something there are some but they aren't
in regards to to hardship generally
we're the local government and you'll
notice is very similar to it to where
the banks are for to be eligible for it
you have to own the property so the big
element with it with it is if you own a
property you've got wealth the issue you
run into is cash flow so what local
authorities do in regard and certainly
the hurdle for a local authority and in
all my time in local government I don't
think I've processed a single
application for remission of rates on
financial hardships because the hurdles
are typically too high so what ends up
happening as council have a number of
policies where they sit back and say
look if your cash flow short then we
will postpone the rates and our earlier
policies effectively postponed it until
you weren't the owner or you died or you
sold the property and and so because of
that that's the way we go so if a
property is mortgaged then the mortgagee
holds security but interestingly rates
stand and fund of a mortgage so first
payment whenever a property sells as
always to meet the rates so in that mix
the common understanding of local
authorities is actually to be fair to
the rest of the community you shouldn't
write somebody's rates off where they
have a valuable asset sitting in the
background that at some stage can be
realized and liquidated and if it does
in the right pair should get paid Lehman
yeah so just just as a follow-on to that
question so what you're suggesting is
going to be available to right tires
these are residential rate payers not
commercial is really just a deferment or
a postponement with a catch up later on
yeah there is actually an effect no
remission for even though the policy
talks about remission we do have at the
end of the policies there are emissions
for any chains yeah there's also one for
remission rates for sports groups but
now we don't remit rates or write rates
off for out okay cool thank you I think
you can Dave in Thank You councillor
Clark I believe I heard some others to
ask Christian's Council of Pottenger
well thank you is it true the current
rates have been sent out now at you July
1 is that right no they do May 20th I
think all right okay so obviously there
was a good point Tony raised there
obviously some people are really you
know like it's Cash's is drying up quick
for a lot of people obviously with May
28th the current rates may be six
anywhere from 600 and 800 to whatever
this policy will not be really by being
as zero as far as the Coast Poneman goes
is there any way that they are allowed
to say hey look I can't afford it this
time but I'll take advantage of the
policy when it comes in or how do we
work this how do we help out by now we
go some thought to how we would word
weird that and in terms of release and I
think you're released so not even just
not a release is ready to go so we have
given thought to that so really what
we're saying to the staff and the staff
have asked that question also in regards
to it
we have as you've noticed this is the
flexibility for us to remit penalties
where we think it's worthwhile to
amenities
so basically when people ring the staff
they will be advised
thank you for ringing we will take note
of your details don't pay the rates and
our penalty will not be charged until
the rates postponement policy has been
considered we couldn't go out and say
just wait for the policy because that
would be predetermination in terms of
we're saying although we're consulting
this policy is absolutely going to go
through and we can't say that so we're
actually treating quite a fine line we
have elements for penalties where we can
be more flexible and typically what
we're looking for as a payment plan and
the next bit so when will people be over
to order we have those items in the
toolkits so they are the ones that will
be applied in the meantime and if this
policy goes ahead slash when this policy
goes ahead whichever we will be getting
back to those rate payers and they can
immediately convert that rate that they
haven't paid on to here and no penalties
will be applied in the meantime right
it's a matter of are we we doing is some
sort of media media release that may
inform people of this intention rather
than just waiting for people have thrown
up and say hey I've got no money
I say that hennas waving her hain so
what I'm assuming is that because I do
know the rates policy postponement media
statement has gone out his Annette Hanna
Nick are you able to answer counselor
pottinger's a question around
communications to ensure that our public
don't wait and put themselves in a worse
off position is probably what you're
looking for is that correct counsel
Hollinger yeah absolutely so last week
we did issue the press release to leat
the media now and also the
public no so that's up on our website
that counselors would be today
considering the postponement policy in
remission policy we also have done some
work on our website through our social
media page as well around making sure
people understand that if they have any
concerns about paying their rates to
contact our team either by phone or by
email for example I myself have received
a few Facebook messages through the
endocardial City Council page and so I
refer those people directly on to our
our rates offices so then it's an
ongoing thing counselor pottinger it
won't simply stop now that we're waiting
for that consultation nor is that
something that I was waiting for their
consultation to enact we are aware that
rate payers are receiving their bills
now and that's creating a little bit of
concern in that space and so it's
something that I'll definitely be
looking to ramp up in the comms space
and the coming days end all weeks so you
know that's really appreciate that
Thanks councillor Soper anything back to
date yeah if I can just point out that
the last day for the payment of the race
that has just been sent out there's
actually the 29th of May I think someone
said 4:20 if it's actually the 29th of
May which means that that timing
actually but some very well with what
Dave and I have just been describing if
there are if there are rate payers who
who can't pay that one it will be very
straightforward to use their remission
policy for that particular period
because the last day the payment for
that penalty is the 29th domain so the
timing is actually going to work quite
well for anyone in that position I'm
assuming you mean counselor so had the
postponement policy the notice that has
just gone out here's a last day of
payment of that portion of rates of the
29th of May so what Dave and henna were
just describing about the possibility
anybody who can't pay that would go into
a penalty area and we could then use our
remission of penalty policy to help
assist that person will fit very well
with that timing make sense okay but it
makes sense what what we've gotten the
postponement policy to me makes perfect
sense and what Henner and Dave Foster
have just been describing makes perfect
sense about the rate that would be
needing to be paid as of the 29th of May
is the last day we are going the
applicator for people who have
difficulty with that payment as well as
the postponement policy we're talking
about now dealing with the next 12
months it's always better to check than
assume thank you I think you cancel at
no okay okay sorry I'm just gonna meet
you Dave out Dave did you have something
to say I was actually just going to when
we had the conversation with staff and
for an assurance for counsel technically
we don't need this policy we actually
could handle what we thought though was
that's a technical analysis so we've
actually written the policy to make it
very clear for people that we are doing
something in regard to Cobra that's
easier for them to comply with so
councilors don't need to worry about the
fact that if this policy is delayed or
slowed down for any reason we can still
effectively come up with an arrangement
that are similar to this under what we
currently have Thank You mr. foster I
think that's important from what I'm
hearing is the concern that we're making
we don't want to make it too difficult
for people in need in our community
right now and this is something that
we've never seen before so I would say
that we underestimate those that are
going to need help with its 20% or
financial hardship so I get a feel from
the screen the
everybody is happy cured it and welcome
to my corner to see you pop up here so
welcome and if if there's someone that
would like to move that we receive our
rates postponement in remissions policy
and that we approve the appended rates
postponement in remissions policy option
one for consultation I do need to pick
up I think she councillor Abbott moved
by Councillor Abbott seconded by
Councillor Ludlow thank you
I do need to pick up counselor clacks a
question around the signaled amount but
can I adopt this policy first effect it
all possible for those staff who have
worked hard to get everything up and
running for us today so with that my
motions been moved and seconded all
those in favor raise your right hand
all those against carries thank you team
so that's done now bit to you councillor
Clark just in relation to signaling the
rates increase you did have a question a
further question about there
you know just just the day really clear
suggested that got a meeting in the next
two to three weeks given that we got to
have weekly meetings that we could we
could progress us so we give some
indications of community and she
suggested that Dave needed time to
prepare for that so I just wanted hasn't
put about how long it would take him to
get his thoughts to get on on a thing or
whether the why she gave it to the last
meeting which is two percent would be an
okay figure to progress with Dave you
muted aadmi it would be wise to have a
report because I think the report puts
it onto the agenda it gets a decision I
can be ready to have a report going up
next week the work the work for the
workshop is effectively all done so
that's not going to change I can put up
a paper to next week's meeting that
would be able to go forward to to agree
what a rate size would be thank you I
appreciate that mr. Foster I do think in
I am my total horror counselors clerks
concerned that their community is
definitely waiting to hear something so
if we are in a position to do their and
we still qualify and meet all the local
government rules and regulations the in
that's a good compromise so thank you
for offering that up next week council
o'clock for you happy birthday if you
just want to give me the thumbs thank
you and we can move on so tame but we're
just about done I just need to give an
indication does anyone need a break
toilet break coffee break I'm happy to
adjourn for five minutes while you go to
the toilet grab yourself a cup of tea
and or you can leave your videos and
everything as they are so I'm happy to
do that before we go into the gambling
policy or we can go through the gambling
policy move into public excluded and
then adjourn choices
I may I think it would be tidier if we
just went through the gaming policy and
then the agent business because that way
also give coms the chance to cut up the
air and then we move into public bring
excluded public agree much more
straightforward right okay let's move on
mean to item 13 on the agenda which is
our gambling policy just bear in mind
that we put this policy on hold and
we're waiting on the outcome of ramadi
contribution to that policy and we are
now in a position where we can adopt
this so I will hand it over
this is under regular tree does that
correct yes ray you cancel it Arnold
and you one inch picture this hello
hello I'm wanting to speak to your
policy counselor it's not a policy
regulatory the Gary policy no not really
no that's quite within policy Tony sorry
sorry what was it it's finance and
policy oh okay thank you very much I was
chucked it true mr. Clark I'll grieve
the policy and I have some question it
really they're really determined by as
we work your way through them I've got
some questions around some of the parts
on policy so probably beers delivered to
them and can I speak Tony
yep just that may well have caught nabhi
on the side there because this was a
postponement of a policy that we started
here under finance and policy under the
previous council yeah it came back for
us to make sure that we had gone through
correct consultation with with E we not
just with tell murmur which is actually
a local obligation but other he we have
we representatives locally it's not
really open for council to discuss at
this point the detail of the policy
because you needed to be there for it
and hear all the submissions so you know
we can't go through and and debating
mechanics we either adopt the policy now
that were confident there's being
sufficient early consultation or would
reject it and start again thanks Johnny
Thank You counselor does though I really
appreciate that reminder in exposition
because I was thinking it was poor eye
counselor adult it was looking at me
sideways I think counselor back so with
that in mind I know that the staff have
worked very hard sending out all the
consultation to ie MALDI organization so
thank you very much for that because I
have been sitting in there I'm happy to
move those recommendations and that we
move that we adopt the gambling policies
review and be received in that the
appended class for gambling venues
policy in the board to obv news policy
their doctors so I believe it Thank You
councillor Ludlow I guess any
discussions around it because it was
done last term and there was submissions
made on it
councillor Clark maybe you can follow
that up with staff afterwards around the
policy through the CEO and
it's beneficial to you and otherwise we
will proceed with it move to adopt the
policy so all those in favor raise your
right hand sorry
and against Tony
I wonder recorder I don't agree with the
policy Thank You councillor clack thank
you
so with that motions passed and I will
move to the thirteen point four which
was the draft policy for the ta B oh no
we've adopted it that's all been adopted
sorry any questions right so I'm gonna
move into public excluded anyone have it
a second there I'm so sorry
yeah before you consider the item could
you please have a resolution it's a
major late item on the basis of time I
move that we accept that is a major late
item council cracker I'm so incredibly
sorry seconded by Councillor that Lowe
thank you all those in favor raise your
right hand against councillor Clark are
you raising or against ting thank all in
favor raise your right hand against
carriage thank you Alex my sincere
apologies to you and maybe you want to
just update us on net like report thank
you thank you so I've been a member now
of the young elected members committee
at the group for my last term and now
again this to means have found
significant value and being able to
connect with other young elected members
throughout the country in support them
and their journeys and learning quite a
bit about the beast that is local
government
they had put out nomination of course
for nominations for all of the zones
throughout New Zealand and they had all
came in and some people had been
appointed and the rest are going through
the nomination and an election process
none we received for his own sex so it
was put out that way we're not going to
have one and I saw that and didn't
believe that that was a good thing that
we don't have at the bottom here with
our team councils any representation so
I got in contact and asked if we could
potentially agree open the nominations
were for an extension and put my name
forward for it and it was accepted so I
would like to ask for your permission or
counsel and your support that to be
nominated as our zone sex representative
so that we have some representation for
the southern councils on a national body
please councillor Clark I moved last
time in that hurry that I'd be happy to
nominate you I still feel that way if
anyone would like to speak to that
please let us know
councillor Soper anyone else thank you
I'm happy to second it because I believe
councillor Craig that has been a very
active member of that body has reported
to us on a couple of occasions that
discussions the year and would make a
very good representative and it's quite
an important part of local government
New Zealand that there is that young
members body so I'm happy to second it
Thank You councillor Soper so sorry it
counts like it I've just been restricted
by cat's tail here so it's been moved
and seconded all those in favour to
support that recommendation please raise
your right hand against Council as I
just want to remind you that I need you
to be voting because I can see people
aren't so pleased if you support that
recommendation
can you please raise your right hands
let's everybody thank you they know one
against thank you very much same make
sure you worship before I move into
public excluded would you like to close
our meeting to the public thank you just
a moment your worship I'm just going to
can you unmute yourself here thank you
Peter
it's just great to see the team has it's
been renamed working together and it
makes it a lot less stressful I think
for everyone involved and it's going
still I know it's we've made fantastic
progress as a country and we can all
feel proud and there was the nurse from
and mcCargo and and neat things have
really happened this journey is far from
over
and we've just got to brace ourselves
and be flexible at the same time and
work through all the issues and that's
what we've done today thank you thank
you your worship
and with that I will move into public
excluded and ask someone to stick in
that motion please thank you you can't
so ever it moved and second all those in
favor against carries thanks you and
before we do sign off thank you to all
the staff who have been working
incredibly hard every day trying to come
up with the different levels of how we
get back to business as usual on our
streets and of the cable so how by
Crytek how to work to you all for doing
all that work sincerely appreciate it
and we'll move into public excluded